make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and today's Beyond Omega level video
is gonna focus on the juggernaut but not
just the regular version of juggernaut
but one specific version that appears in
just a couple of issues but is
undoubtedly the most powerful version
that the characters ever pinned the
first thing we need to do is go over who
the juggernaut is and what his powers
are in his normal form then we'll get
into a discussion of what made him so
powerful for a brief period of time and
what he was capable of doing during that
time so juggernauts real name is Ken
Marcou and he was created by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby and made his debut in
x-men number 12 in 1965 so he's been
doing battle with the x-men almost since
the inception of the team but Cain
Marcos father marries Charles Xavier z--
mother after Charles father dies and
Cain becomes jealous of the affection
that his father shows Charles and ends
up bullying him now while both are
serving in the Korean War
Cain discovers an ancient temple and
inside finds a huge ruby bearing the
inscription whosoever touches this gem
shall be granted the power of the
crimson gem of cyttorak henceforth you
who read these words shall become
forevermore a human juggernaut now upon
touching the gym the temple caves in and
Cain is buried under the rubble and then
presumed dead now what actually happens
however is that upon touching the gym
Kame becomes an avatar force it Iraq who
is an extremely powerful demon that's
existed for over a millennia and
inhabits a dimension called the crimson
cosmos since he was banished from earth
now over a thousand years ago sin Iraq
made a wager with seven other mystical
beings where each of them created an
object that would house a fraction of
their power and turn the first human who
touched it into their avatar but we'll
get deeper into who Sid Iraq is if we
ever do a video on him for this series
so let me know in the comments if you
want to see a beyond omega-level video
on Sid Iraq himself is probably worth it
sin Iraq is ridiculously overpowered but
any event what's important for us to
know here is that when Cain Marko
touches the gym he becomes the
juggernaut and is imbued with a fraction
of sinner acts power now as a result
juggernaut is granted a variety of
powers some of which he's kept and some
of which he's lost but most notably his
superhuman strength and durability he's
kept just to get an idea of how strong
the juggernaut is he's able to overpower
Thor in trade blows with the Hulk during
the world war hulk event when Hulk was
near his strongest form and when
was in his regular form juggernaut was
nearly able to break his neck he's able
to throw tanks hold up collapsing
skyscrapers and even temporarily
restrain captain universe who can
harness the ultra powerful cosmic force
known as the unit power now in terms of
durability juggernaut is nearly
invulnerable having been unfazed by
Thor's God blast as well as several
blows from Mjolnir and is not harmed via
blast from the stranger a cosmic entity
on Park with Galactus in terms of power
jefra naught also possesses enhanced
speed and once he begins moving it's
thought to be impossible to stop him
furthermore juggernaut is able to
generate protective force fields as long
as his helmet remains in place he's
immune to telepathic attacks even from
the most powerful psychics in the Marvel
Universe but all this though impressive
doesn't even get juggernaut close to
being Omega level for that we have to go
back to 1999 and an event known as the
Tryon saga
now the Tryon saga was a crossover story
written by Allen Davis it takes place in
uncanny x-men number 368 x-men number 88
and uncanny x-men number 369 and so what
is up happening here is that a group of
x-men are mysteriously abducted by a
mysterious figure named Edgehill and
transported to another dimension against
their will now when they get there they
realize that in this dimension their
powers do not work the same way that
they normally do now this guy L job ends
up informing them that he was sent to
retrieve them by the Troy on the
sentient manifestations of the forces
that make up the dimension he further
explains that the x-men are needed
because they have specific experience
battling the enemy that's threatening
his people the juggernaut now at this
point it's revealed that it was actually
another longtime x-men
ed job and his people about the x-men a
guy named Black Tom Cassidy who explains
the events that led up to juggernaut
plaguing this dimension now black Tom
explains the juggernaut had found out
about a second Jim house at the temple
of Sid Iraq and tried to retrieve it in
hopes of doubling his power and doing so
juggernaut walked into a trap set by a
cult who needed juggernauts energy to
charge up the second Jim and SAP
juggernaut of his power now wanting to
help his friend of regain his power
block Tom enlisted the help of storm
gambit and Kitty Pryde to retrieve the
second Jim which he gives the juggernaut
now when juggernaut absorbs the power of
the second Jim however he becomes
possessed by a mindless rage and goes on
an uncontrolled rampage what happens
then is that juggernaut punches a hole
in the fabric of space-time and in doing
so rips a hole in the barrier that
separates the main Marvel you
verse from the universe where the x-men
now find themselves and so black Tom is
also transported to the new dimension
and rescued by a jobs people he explains
that juggernaut is being directed by an
evil instinct and even though the Trion
is trying to throw him off course by
sending him to other dimensions
juggernaut is making his way back to
their reality to destroy it and his
destroying dimensional barriers along
the way and so when the x-men
encountered juggernaut in this dimension
he's 80 feet tall suggesting that he's
able to change size at will which also
suggests that he's capable of a degree
of matter manipulation furthermore we
see juggernaut at this size is battling
several giant beasts at one time and
emerging not only victorious but without
a scratch now beyond this we don't know
exactly what juggernaut is capable of
because we don't really see him in this
form very long but what happens is that
Professor X actually projects himself
into the astral plane his astral form
comes into contact with Wolverine and
the professor's mind sort of hangs out
in Wolverines body along with his own
mind for a bit but eventually Wolverine
and the professor literally enter
juggernauts mind through his helmet now
once inside the juggernauts mind they
separate and convince the psyche of Cain
Marko to drive out the force dess
possessing him and retake control of his
mind and when he does so a second hole
is ripped in the space-time continuum as
juggernaut is returned to his normal
size and Professor X's astral form
leaves Wolverine and returns to his own
body and so what we end up learning is
that there was actually a secret evil
element residing within the Trion that
it's summon juggernaut to their
dimension in hopes that he would destroy
it now he undoubtedly would have done so
so he had broken through dimensional
barriers with ease before arriving in
the Tri ons dimension and so once the
Trion realized what had happened they
enlisted the help of the x-men to try
and stop the juggernaut which of course
they did and though we don't get to see
as much of this version of the
juggernaut as we would have liked you
because this was done before every story
arc was built to run long enough to fill
up at least a trade paperback we see
enough of juggernaut to know that he's
beyond Omega level not only do we have
his usual arsenal of powers but he's
been amped up to the point where he can
literally threaten reality by ripping
holes in the very fabric that holds it
together so had we been able to see the
destruction he'd caused before his
run-in with the x-men we would have
likely had a much longer list of feats
that we could point to and honestly I
wish they had done more with this story
and written a more climactic ending to
it as it just sort of ends abruptly
without any real resolution but any
right this is by far the most powerful
version of juggernaut that we've ever
seen and I feel like
we confer another due to the nature of
juggernauts powers that when he's
augmented to this degree he would likely
be able to run through and destroy
entire planets in the main Marvel
Universe who would that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come this explain
to make sure you guys to the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace I want to say thank you to
all of the new patrons who have joined
patreon.com slash comics explained I
want to give a shout out to Henry young
- Elias G David J s Jakob H Ben John H
Jason see Austin s Austin H James O
kristymatt in Jeff are Joey M Steven Z
sloth-like lu-david C John H lean and
mean that guy asked questions all the
time Adam Cajun gnosis 9/16 I want to
say thank you to all of you all this
list is growing all the time leave your
join to the patreon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]